president-elect biden's transition team
has had a new problem with the trump
administration
this after the pentagon announced that
it's suspending daily security briefings
for the rest of the year for what it
calls a holiday break it comes as mr
biden is preparing to add some new
firsts today in what promises to be the
most diverse cabinet in u.s history
the president-elect is also making time
to get a coronavirus vaccination
ed o'keefe is with mr biden in
wilmington delaware this morning
um ed we saw president-elect biden head
to georgia this past week out of those
two senate runoff elections
on january 5th should we expect more
visits from him
moving forward we might see that but
first we know that mr biden and his wife
dr jill biden are going to be vaccinated
for covet 19
on monday making good on a pledge to
take the vaccine
in public today as you mentioned he's
set to make a few more
announcements and a few more historic
firsts as he names people to his cabinet
first up he's set to nominate new mexico
congresswoman deb holland to serve
as head of the interior department if
confirmed she'd be the first native
american to lead the department that has
oversight of about one-fifth of the
nation's land
including federally controlled tribal
areas a big first there he's also
planning to nominate
michael regan to lead the environmental
protection agency
he's currently head of north carolina's
environmental protection department
and would be the first black man to lead
that agency meanwhile there is
disagreement between the biden team and
the trump administration over access to
the pentagon
acting defense secretary chris miller
says that his team in the biden team
had mutually agreed to put off some
meetings scheduled for friday
until after the holidays but the head of
the biden transition told reporters
that's not true
and that his team continues to face
quote isolated resistance from political
appointees
in the defense department and similar
issues at a few other agencies he
declined to name
the acting secretary chris miller says
the pentagon has been
more than helpful so far scheduling
hundreds of meetings for the biden team
and having handing over thousands of
documents that they've requested but
this is at least one example
of some of the bumps in the road on the
way to the white house for the biden
team jeff
well ed we are watching those
negotiations right now in the senate and
how tough they are what should
president-elect biden expect if
democrats are not able to gain that
majority
right so again the georgia race is being
held on january 5th for those two open
senate seats
uh the campaigning continues there if
democrats can win both of those seats
the senate will be divided 50 50 with
vice president
elect soon to be vice president kamala
harris serving as the tiebreaker that
makes it slightly easier
for the button administration to get
things done working on
uh you know more expanded relief for
americans
struggling through the pandemic getting
cabinet nominees quickly confirmed
taking up issues like climate change or
immigration reform
other changes that the binding
administration would like to make so if
it's republicans however they control
the senate then obviously there's going
to be a lot more deal making that has to
happen
that's why this past week's interactions
between the president-elect and the
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
were an encouraging sign
that they're at least starting to talk
in the event that those two have to
start cutting deals
that might you know upset people on
either side of the
aisle but will be necessary to get
things done all right ed o'keefe ed
thank you